boote bauen statt geld verleihen
andreas dörr war früher banker jetzt
veranstaltet er drachenbootrennen
ich glaube dieses wort arbeit so belegt
vielleicht auch mit einer gewissen
schwere und man muss arbeiten gehen
das empfinde ich nicht so sondern ich
habe mich davon gelöst weil es eben
mainz ist ob es die berufung war ich
habe das gefühl mit der perspektive kann
man glaube ich immer erst ein bisschen
mehr sehen aber ich fühle
mich gut und kraftvoll und möchte die
dinge die ich mache weiter entwickeln
und insofern glaube ich bin ich schon
eher an der berufung als wenn man sagt
man hat nur so abstrakten kleinen beruf
den man jetzt für jemand aus führt
katharina bruns betreute die werbekunden
eines großen konzerns stadt online
kampagnen zu starten
kehrt sie nun zurück zu handfestem sie
entwirft bastelsets mit denen man
taschen schals oder schmuck selbst
herstellen kann
für mich war der leidensdruck
tatsächlich auch zu hoch und ich war
eigentlich komplett unterforderten das
ist ja eigentlich der witz an der sache
dass dort die leute ausbrennen weil ich
meine wir hatten natürlich stress man
hat stress und so weiter aber man ist
eigentlich menschlich unterfordert also
die jobs sind zu klein für das was wir
eigentlich leisten können die bastel
kisten werden vor allem von frauen
gekauft die wieder lust auf altmodische
handarbeit haben alle zwei monate bringt
sie zusammen mit ihrer
geschäftspartnerin eine neue idee heraus
dann gehen regelmäßig mehrere tausend
bestellungen im workshop ein
na klar also ich hatte schon alle
annehmlichkeiten hat den sehr guten job
und ich habe in der selbständigkeit am
anfang nicht so viel verdient wie jetzt
für die nicht mehr und sie kann sich
ihre zeit selber einteilen arbeit und
freizeit ist bei ihr kein gegensatz
jobs sind das was andere von mir wollen
und erwarten arbeit ist das was ich
selbst vermittelt und was ich selbst von
mir erwarte und ist ein riesiger
unterschied sich darüber klar zu werden
kann
das ganze leben verändern vor allem
akademiker sind mit ihrer arbeit oft
unzufrieden
uta glaubitz erklärt in seminaren wie es
klappen kann den beruf zu wechseln wenn
man nur so irgendwas rein gerät weil am
besser nichts besseres einfällt dass
entwickelt keine kraft und dadurch
kostet einen beruf unheimlich viel gibt
an aber nichts zurück als er gibt einen
zurück ja dass man seine miete bezahlt
und das ist ja auch schön so aber es
gibt eine menge leute sagen es ist
nicht genug sie möchten etwas machen was
mehr mit ihnen zu tun hat wie zum
beispiel die leidenschaft für den
rudersport die jetzt teil von andreas
görs arbeit ist auch er hat sich beraten
lassen
inzwischen organisiert er mehr als 80
sportevents jedes jahr für bis zu 1000
leute firmen buchen bei ihm zum beispiel
drachenbootrennen zur
mitarbeitermotivation risiken einzugehen
mit frau und kindern ist das nicht immer
so leicht
es gibt immer wieder phasen wo man sich
hinterfragen muss ist das richtig wenn
man an seine grenzen kommt deshalb auch
diese wachheit und gucken und auch ein
stück demut das man sagt so gerade wenn
es großartig und grandios läuft ist hat
nichts zu sagen aber genauso auch wenn
man vielleicht am boden liegt mal gucken
wer weiß wofür es gut ist
erstmal ist der 46 jährige zufrieden so
wie es ist wie es weitergeht das lässt
er in ruhe auf sich zukommen